With a running time of about two-and-a-half
hours, Captain America: Civil War is one stuffed
movie. It features about four action-heavy
set-pieces, a dozen superheroes beating each
other up, political machinations, and even
a couple of bromances thrown in for good measure.
As a result, some scenes just had to hit the
cutting room floor. As ever, beware: spoilers
ahead.
Meet Ant-Man
When we meet Ant-Man before the big super-throwdown
at the airport in Germany, he more or less
just jumps out of a van and shakes hands with
Captain America. But as it turns out, the
tiny hero's introduction in the script was
originally, well, bigger. Get it, cause he grows? He grows big.
According to a Slashfilm interview with Civil
War's screenwriters Christopher Markus and
Stephen McFeely, the script originally called
for a scene with Lang and the gang in his
home of San Francisco. But it was deleted
because it didn't get Ant-Man's tone quite
right. Markus explained:
"We were probably wrong. Because of the nature
of when we start making the movie versus when
it comes out, as we’re doing it for Infinity
War, we wrote a lot, if not all, of Scott
Lang’s stuff before we ever saw Ant-Man.
You just have to roll with that because we
need to film."
Where's Wasp?
Speaking of Ant-Man, fans were excited by
that movie's post-credits scene that alluded
to the impending debut of the hero's crime-fighting
partner, the Wasp. I mean maybe she'd appear with
Ant-Man in Civil War, right? That's apparently
something the filmmakers actually wanted to
happen.
But Marvel Studios head Kevin Feige explained
it was more important to preserve her superheroic
journey for the Ant-Man sequel.
Talk it out
After the Winter Soldier is captured in Germany,
the heroes gather and discuss what's going
on. These scenes continue to inform who's
on which side of the movie's conflict, and
why. But Civil War's directors, Joe and Anthony
Russo, decided not all conversations are created
equally.
Joe Russo explained to ComicBook.com that
a Black Widow and Black Panther chat was cut
to keep things rolling:
"There was a scene between Natasha and T’Challa
at the German Ops Center, halfway through
the movie when he was sitting in that room.
Cap and Falcon had been isolated in the other
conference room. We didn’t feel like it
was moving the storytelling forward and they
had already had a scene so it felt repetitive
so it was something we excised from the movie."
Cap dies?
The end of Captain America: Civil War shows
Cap ultimately winning his brawl with Iron
Man, and living to fight another day. But
at the end of the comic book version of Civil
War, Cap meets his maker.
As it happens, a ScreenRant interview with
screenwriters McFeely and Markus reveals that they
never even considered offing Captain America.
Killing off Cap, said McFeely, would've undercut
the ambiguity they were aiming for with the
issues presented by the Sokovia Accords:
"It also makes him too definitely a martyr
and makes it feel like he was right. And we
wanted neither side to be right or wrong.
We wanted to end it kind of queasy. Both opinions
are still standing at the end of the movie."
And considering how great the final film turned
out, it's pretty hard to argue with their
decision.
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the one
you just saw. And leave us a comment to let
us know which deleted scene you would've liked
to see most...